hey freunde da ist er wieder euer
lieblings youtuber ich bin
guckt mal andere youtuber alter eine
damen ohne fenster eingeblendet es ist
weihnachten das meint also ich glaube
auch nicht dass im titel steht das ist
weihnachten aber es ist weiter frei es
ist auch nicht mal weihnachten ist
einfach nur dezember gerade einen doppel
was macht man denn alles gute er ist
kaputt gegangen wenn wir die nicht mal
irgendwo so schönen hintergrund stellen
manager kommt er richtig
weihnachtsstimmung auch in der tat ich
als fünfjähriges kleines mädchen mag
natürlich die weihnachtszeit besonders
gern weil nicht wegen geschenken sondern
nur wegen liebe und zuneigung und nicht
aber neben all diesen tollen familiären
sachen gibt es natürlich in der
adventszeit auch adventskalender und
deswegen meine softbox für gerade fast
den tisch runter deswegen habe ich mir
gedacht im heutigen video packen wir
einfach mal an wenn es keinen dass die
beschissenen adventskalender zeiten ich
habe ich einmal den bibi und tina
adventskalender adventkalender
adventskalender nicht verstehst und dann
habe ich ja auch noch den bibi
blocksberg der total verhext
adventskalender
wir machen das heute auf
weihnachten zunächst einmal schauen wir
uns hier den biotin adventskalenders
gute hier an ist wir können das doch
ganz wie sie alles direkt auf einmal
auspacken
das hier sind die einzelnen türchen wir
machen jetzt mal das erste türchen
zusammen auf meine damen und herren wo
haben wir es denn hier haben wir das
erste türchen oder können ist einfach
die liebe rücken können dass wir auch
machen und wir sehen gott sie hat ihren
kopf verloren
das hier war hinter türchen nummer eins
ich würde sagen wir nennen sie es der
baby oder ist das thema was ich schon
mal ganz kurz nach ich glaube das ist
china nicht funktioniert oder du warst
hinter dem ersten türchen im
adventskalender das heißt du bekommst
einen ganz besonderen platz in meiner
wohnung gehen der kopf schon wieder
abgeflogen
halo kabul dann schauen wir noch mal ist
natürlich nur ein
warum hat andreas jetzt halt stopp
geschrieben thomas selber nachdenken
über einen dummen fragen ich weiß heute
ist der erste dezember aber ich bin ein
neugieriges kleines fünfjähriges mädchen
wir haben hinter türchen nummer zwei
mein gott eine katze tina was sagst du
da nicht mal mehr den kopf das ist
tatsächlich megageil wir können einfach
ziehen das beinahe so weit auseinander
strecke tina china reitet auf ihrem
pferd und schaut euch das mal anders sie
total wie ich sie leitet forum tina und
ihr fährt ich würde sagen die beiden
bekommt auch einen wundervollen platz in
meiner holen nämlich dort wie oft wird
ihn das kopf eigentlich noch abfallen
hier ist ganze video ist übrigens nicht
gesponsert von bibi und tina oder bibi
blocksberg oder irgendwas ich glaube
sogar er wenn sie dieses video hier
entdecken werden dass sie versuchen mich
an zu zeigen aber meine damen und herren
wir schauen uns mal das dritte türchen
an und zwar ist es ein sehr ähnliches
türchen was haben wir denn da drin wir
haben auch mein gott es ist nicht krieg
dich raus eine ewigkeit spielte die
berlin
bauer meine damen und herren geil noch
sondern richtig coolen historischen
gestrichen nummer vier wir machen die
klappe auf ist diesmal sehr klein wir
haben die klappe abgerissen
hintertürchen 4 befindet sich meine
damen und haltet euch fest es ist etwas
unglaubliches es ist wirklich unfassbar
ich kriege endlich auch ich kann es
nicht fassen was wir wirklich hier
hinter haben schaut es euch an es ist
einfach einen treffer packte gabel
ich schwöre euch dann hinter türchen
nummer fünf jetzt nichts geiles ist dann
gehen wir über zum blocksberg
adventskalender türchen nummer bewahren
was denn hier vorne auf den relativ
kleines türchen am strom in ballen stroh
an wie bisher an der stelle frage ich
mich einfach so wie wir und china grenzt
ja eine supertolle mehr werden wir hier
gebracht ich zeige euch nochmal was wir
bisher alles drin hatten wir hatten tina
die tatsächlich mit ihren beinen
also ja genau also wir hatten mit dem
ersten türchen tina dann hätten wir
hinter dem zweiten thürig hinein was war
das ein elefant glaube ich oder
irgendwie sowie der türchen nummer drei
hatten wir die berliner mauer meine
damen und herren es hat mich tatsächlich
mit am meisten gefallen hinter dem
vierten türchen hatten wir dann eine
mistgabel die ich immer noch nicht aus
der verpackung aus bekommen haben und in
der 5 türig in einen ballen heu wo ich
mich tatsächlich immer noch frage und
die tu kürze ausbeute wow wow
bevor wir jetzt allerdings die mini
blocksberg adventskalender mal aufmachen
und uns dort die ersten fünf bis 40
türchen anschauen eine ganz kurze sache
meine damen und herrn und zwar ist ja
heute der erste zwölfte wenn ihr das
video seht es gerade schon abend also es
ist jetzt nicht mehr nachmittag ist
logisch wenn wir heute abend ist
allerdings weiß dass aktive luxus
mitglied natürlich erste zwölfter hat
weil luca da klingelt doch irgendwo was
genau da lautet man fast 90 menschen da
ist also heute ist wirklich bei mir im
dieser zweiter mit eingestickt hallo
mein name ist und also sonderzeichen ist
gelaunched dieser zweiter mit einem
riesigen luke print ist gelaunt
dieses shirt ist doch wurscht mit einem
lucio print in oranges gelaunt und ein
multi core oder auch mit lucio
eingesteckt in verschiedenen farben hier
an den ärmeln mit so pastelltöne dieses
viele sachen sind gelaunt und auch noch
socken da hab ich allerdings selber noch
keine bekommen die gibt es auch heute im
luca shop willkommen sofort zum bibi
blocksberg adventskalender ja meine
damen und herren ich wollte mich doch
mal ganz kurz entschuldigen und zwar für
heute den launch mitbekommen habt um 15
uhr der ist kompletter ist gallier ja
wie ein baldiges ist schon auseinander
genau ich wollte mich an der stelle noch
mal ganz kurz dafür entschuldigen wir
haben die server aus dem maximum
aufgestockt wir haben da experten am
start alles mögliche aber trotzdem zu
viele leute ihr seid so krank war ihr
könnt jetzt vernünftig bestellen also
wenn ihr was haben möchte von den neuen
sachen dann schaut jetzt gern mal vorbei
[Musik]
also meine damen und herren das hier ist
der nächster dance kinder bibi
blocksberg ist sie verwandt mit babys
beauty palace wir suchen mal das erste
türchen
das haben wir nämlich genau daher gibt
es überhaupt erst durch ein tier ist das
erste türchen meine damen und herren da
können wir einfach mal so ein ding
hinter klappen das ganze auf machen und
wir haben das ist das ist doch nicht
deren ernst man das ist doch nicht das
ist das ist müll und dann kann ich hier
so machen und dann geht's nicht mal
richtig rum in lucka shop gelb so was er
nicht so was qualitativ minderwertiges
bibi blocksberg gang schauen wir doch
aber nun mal freunde was sich hinter dem
zweiten türchen für mit 2000 jahre
später damals auch schon gefunden
nämlich weiß dass man hier auf und wir
haben tatsächlich hinter dem zweiten
meine damen und ich kann es gar nicht
abwarten ich kriege noch gar nicht raus
oh mein gott geis 1
seine skepsis wir haben 10
das ist glaube ich ein tier oder weiß
ich nicht genau und damit kann man
lätzchen backen war mäßig gas bekommt
einen ganz besonderen platz im mülleimer
davor natürlichen nummer drei meine
damen und herren die drei ist meine
lieblingszahl das hat glaube ich noch
nie jemand gesagt wir stecken unsere
finger hier rein oder versuchen es halt
auch gegen eine andere art und weise
offen zu machen nämlich zwo mit dem
daumen und reißen es so aussehen dann
hinter dem türchen 3 o mein gott haben
ein bisschen was größte bringen
ko-tropfen verhext clever schleim bibi
blocksberg crew las war 50.000 likes
daran mache ich dem nächsten video in
dem ich den gewässer türchen nummer vier
meine damen und herren ist tatsächlich
diesmal wirklich meine lieblingszahl hat
glaube ich auch noch nie jemand gesagt
deine lieblings die 21 was eure
lieblings alles könnte ja gerne in die
kommentare schreiben haben wir haben
hier hin da etwas ein online stempel
oder war 10 9 8 7 6 5 4 9 ich dachte
jetzt einfach mal los und wir sehen war
es ist halt einfach nur weh getan bibi
blocksberg gegen oder wie auch immer
wieder genannt haben dieser stelle
bekommt tatsächlich auf das besondere
diesmal war ich habe nicht mal getroffen
türchen nummer fünf meine damen und
herren ist meine lieblingszahl die
nummer fünf das heißt da muss doch jetzt
eigentlich etwas krasses hinter sein so
waren wir die fünf hier oben ist die
fünf freunde das heißt wir kriegen jetzt
einfach mal drauf klicken da drauf ja
wahrscheinlich und ihr hinter meine
damen und herren ja wer hätte denn
gedacht ist das schön oder geil wir
haben ein puzzle
wow warum das habe ich nie verstanden wo
liegt die faszination bei einem puzzle
es ist ein bild was auseinander
geschnitten ist und man muss es wieder
zusammen
warum warum machen dass leute ich bin
glaube ich wirklich der einzige mensch
doch nie irgendwie ein puzzle also ich
hab schon mal puzzles gemacht in der
schule oder sonnencremes aber ich hab's
noch nie gefeiert
all das ist wenn man darüber nachdenkt
ist einfach nur dumm wenn man zu viel
zeit hat kann man das nicht machen und
auch wenn das heute feiern dann habe ich
da auch überhaupt nichts gegen habe ich
also in meinen augen
jetzt hat alonso freunde habe mich würd
sagen ist ja nicht so machen jetzt die
sechs auf sondern wir gehen wir hier
direkt auf die 14 zu
und schau mal die vierte nicht ein
bisschen und länglich sag mal bin ich zu
blöd dass aufzumachen hinter der 14
verbirgt sich freunde ich hoffe ein
tattoo von einer band oder so aber nein
wir haben was auch immer das selbst ich
glaube das sind pflaster ich weiß zwar
ehrlich gesagt nicht wo das dran passen
soll dann schaut man meinen daumen pasta
allein schon der ist größer als ein
pflaster aber gut
ich mein ich als fünfjähriges mädchen
wenn ich mir mal beim popel meinen
finger brechen kann nicht in der bibi
blocksberg pflaster benutzen
an der stelle wird das video ist
allerdings auch beenden meine damen und
herren ich habe es bei beiden kalendern
bei dem einen habe ich 50 gerechnet und
bei dem sechs der kalender da unten war
aber auch echt nicht so geil überhaupt
nichts gegen bibi und tina wie
blocksberg keine ahnung was finde ich
mega cool dass ich diese dinge bei mir
im postkasten hatte aber ich bin
mittlerweile 70 jahre alt damit ihr mich
nicht mehr verrückt dass ich mir
gefallen hat freunde dann hast du auch
gerne mal ein like da wie gesagt heute
ist das neue merchandise gelaunte findet
oben wieder werbe video eingeblendet
muss man jetzt mal dieses in deutschland
machen wenn ihr die sachen haben möchte
schaut vorbei in haltern glas wasser
ziehen
das war's jetzt ihr vom video hier
können jetzt hier mal den kanal
abonnieren oder hier unten meinem shop
ausschenken ihr findet ihr zwei andere
videos und wenn ihr schon abonnent sein
könnt ihr auch die glocke klicken dann
willkommen die benachrichtigungen
[Musik]